écoutez contenu que j'ai quitté
l'express il ya un an que je fais plutôt
pmp je vis sur mes économies on va dire
est que je ça me permet de mettre en
place pas mal de projets accord voilà
que ce soit comme scénariste médiateur
mais là votre venue ces couacs sauf que
rien mais revenus bas alors j'ai pôle
emploi d'une part comme beaucoup à pôle
emploi
oui ah bah oui mais oui puisque j'ai
quitté l'express tout ça donc là oui je
suis à pôle emploi
voilà donc les coûts t on se débrouille
toi voilà alors c'est vrai que mon
christophe je sais plus pourquoi n'ayant
il fait plus toutes les pme ouvert à
tous si nous regardent j'espère qu'il va
voir on va essayer de le remettre sur tp
ouvert à tous mais c'est vrai que moi ça
m'a ça m'a touché le témoignage de
christophe et gilles vous parfois série
que vous rester trois mois sans faire
l'émission est ce que vous êtes
voilà vous êtes en restera ou pas du
tout puisque je vous jure que c'est vrai
mais en fait je fais des missions mais
sûr je pense à vous et j'essaie de vous
appeler don envoyé des messages tout ça
mais c'est vrai que voilà cc je sais que
ça peut être extrêmement compliqué
moralement c'est pas du tout la même
chose c'est pas du tout la même vie
quand on fait les missions et quand on
ne la fait pas ça c'est vrai on vit
différemment et comme moi je vis
professionnellement pour vous presque à
100 merci je reste intégralement
c'est vrai que quand on n'est pas là on
se demande
quand on va être appelé si on va être
appelé donc c'est un certain c'est vrai
que c'est un certain et c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile à vivre je suis et
mieux en le disant parce que en fait il
ya tellement d'implication quand on est
là tellement on est à 100% moi je suis à
fond vous le savez du matin au soir
et quand on n'est pas là du coup il ya
un grand vide mais un vide littérale le
vide de ne pas bosser et le vide humain
ne pas voir les gens et de se dire mais
à quoi ma journée va être utilisé donc
je vous avoue oui que c'est compliqué
avez vous comprenez que parfois il ya
des choix à faire dans l'émission c'est
vrai que je ne leur ai jamais dit je
sais je sais alors jamais bon il ne
s'est jamais plaint gila mais c'est
vraiment et nicolas vous c'est un autre
truc c'est qu'au départ
vous êtes venu une ou deux fois après
plus du tout et puis après thierry vous
avez trouvé votre place dans l'émission
est ce que le moment vous n'êtes plus du
tout venu est ce que vous aviez doute
est ce que vous ça vous a mis sa
tendresse moi je suis venu pendant quoi
une semaine d'ailleurs on s'était amusé
avec gilles verdez vous aviez fait le
vous savez vous aviez mis le fauteuil de
nation of the voice donc on avait pas
mal rigolé comme ça pendant une semaine
et puis tout d'un coup ça s'est arrêté
donc ça a été un peu surprenant parce
que c'est vrai que c'est une habitude et
puis alors mais aussi autre chose c'est
que moi je vais vous avez d'autres fois
vous me charrier avec le le fait de
parler temps en temps aux gentils avec
moi j'ai besoin de parler je viens de
parler je prends pas la tête mais je
parle avec les gens échangent et
j'échange avec votre public entre autres
qui est fidèle et qui est très sympa
donc j'essaye toujours sur instagram mot
sur twitter de répondre aux gens quand
c'est une interpellation un peu
sympathique donc c'est vrai que quand ça
servait religion alors il voulait lâcher
un peu vous avez lu ce retour déjà will
say boulons mais en tout cas le truc ya
c'est que c'est vrai qu'on est habitué
c'est assez un peu les gens se rendent
pas compte c'est vrai que c'est un
investissement on travaille quand même
pour chaque émission pendant quelques
heures pour certains et est peut-être un
peu moins pour d'autres mais mes deux
benjamins non on a ri boss non ils
bossent vachement benjamin puisque on
s'appelle jacques anouma et on échange
des trucs banier ce que je veux dire
c'est vrai que c'est il ya il ya
vraiment une famille malgré ce que les
gens disent le temps au temps diderot et
à nous la machin ou truc des pmp c'est
une vraie famille et on a l'habitude de
se rencontrer et de parler ensemble
après l'émission on a eu on a plus
d'affinités avec certains que d'autres
genres ce cas c'est vrai qu'on a cette
habitude maintenant quasi quotidienne
d'être là le soir alors après l'arrêt
c'est toujours pareil sont des questions
personnelles
personne n'est sûr de soi autour de
cette table on est tous un
et la question de temps en temps c'est
dire est ce que c'est une punition ou
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai pas été bon et
ce que voilà on se remet en question
on voit moins bien évidemment reviendra
peut-être plus tard mais c'est le jeu ma
plus tard paul ryan a aussi auquel je
pense moi c'est moctar qui mixe c'est
dur pour lui en ce moment puisqu'il n'y
a pas de public est forcément pas de
sécu et c'est vrai que je pense à mon
frérot mokhtar et là vraiment lui il
j'ai hâte que le public puisse revenir
là on n'a pas eu des bonnes nouvelles
mais c'est vrai que vraiment j'ai hâte
qu'il puisse revenir parce que pour
retrouver aussi mon mokhtar oui isabelle
mais gilles dit quand on a quand on ne
m'a rien à côté tout mais moi moi
objectivement gr terre à côté mais c'est
vrai que c'est tout à fait dans la même
ambiance mais et d'avancer pas la même
sur rtl insignia stéphane boudsocq alors
c'est un collègue à elle à chaque fois
il nourrit nous met dans la gueule
barils alors qu'ils à côté d'eux dans
laissez vous tenter
c'est ce qui va se passer c'est qu'un
matin je vous en ai moi même avec ces
vous tomber les bras à 4 heures du matin
un seul site et tous les gens de la
sécurité y voit une foule joyeuse vol
mais je pense que lui avec moi tout
jouable mais la sécurité sera là pour
lui j'espère oui et donc objectivement
c'est vrai que c'était une famille et
c'est vrai que quand on n'est pas loin
des merdes j'ai bien le truc qui a pas
plu ou g où j'ai été chiant tous les
gens ne même plus parce qu'il ya vous et
les gens ont des têtes que les gens nous
aiment plus quand on n'est pas large
vous dire un truc c'est les trahir un
secret 1 vous dit gilles et on va le dit
c'est vrai que même quand vous n'étiez
pas là vous étiez payé par exemple ou
alors on a un contrat voilà c'est ça un
nombre d'émissions par semaine donc vous
êtes payés par le nombre d'éditions vous
faites même si vous n'êtes même si vous
ne les fait pas oui mais si on est là
voilà on n'a pas le choix si on est
lundi vous aviez signé pour combien
d'émissions par trois émissions par
semaine oui bah dont vous êtes payé
trois élus sur wii mais je ne plains pas
du tout mais que vous veniez ou pas ben
oui mais si je viens plus de fois je
suis plus payer sinon il ya un traître
un minimum de trois émissions par
semaine à me voler mon e mais c'est sûr
et vous devez prendre une dérouillée
c'est à dire que vous êtes payé quoi
qu'il arrive
ah oui oui si tu lisais d'être payés à
rien faire ah c'est vrai qu'il fallait
et ben moi je vous dire je culpabilise
et ne vous payé à rien [ __ ] au site
les chéris qu'est ce qui a changé à main
mais moi j'ai très mal je vous le dis
les derniers on sait moins vu parce
qu'il y avait le profil mans il m'avait
quatre personnes n'étaient pas sur les
missions et moi je les ai vécus très
très mal et on a posé beaucoup de
questions c'est vrai c'est une vraie
angoisse et on se dit qu'est ce qu'on a
fait de mal qu'est ce qu'on n'a pas fait
mais c'est très vrai rien fait de mal
c'est vraiment voilà c'est aussi voit la
cccc voilà les missions parfois vous
avez une émission là plein de visages
mais là j'aimerais voilà et est plein de
design différent donc quelquefois on a
besoin de visages de tels profils
d'autres profils
c'est vrai que l'équipe change peu en ce
moment parce que l'affairé qu'on a
trouvé une vitesse de croisière un but
est de croisière incroyable mais bien
sûr il y en a qu'on voit moins en ce
moment qu'ils reviendront très très vite
et qui me manque
aussi je vous le dis j'aurais dit je
voulais ajouter quelque chose monsieur
mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
parce que c'est quand même un métier
malgré tout on amour du désir des autres
le désir de l'autre en l'occurrence et
vous cyril donc forcément quand on n'est
pas appelée autour de la table ce à quoi
dire je vous aime pas non mais bien sûr
que non mais sauf qu'on le prend parfois
on se remet en question sur dit castro
n'a pas bien fait est ce qu'on n'a pas
fait une bonne émission ou n'être qu on
n'a pas parlé
enfin on n'a pas parlé en bon moment on
va là dont on doute et ça nous ça nous
remet aussi un petit coup de pression et
moi je voudrais dire aussi puisque ça on
est dans un contexte où vite
qu'aujourd'hui encore plus cette année
je mesure la chance que j'ai de pouvoir
sortir de la maison d'aller bosser de
retrouver une équipe des collègues la
voir des gens qui nous pompent sommes
des techniciens des gens qui nous
maritime quoi je trouve qu'on est au
bord du moins extrêmement chanceux de
pouvoir sortir de sa maison il pas
l'être en télétravail et voilà je trouve
qu'on est des privilégiés d'accord fait
autant outre l'aspect financier qui est
aussi un énorme aspect davantage les
origines
moi je voudrais il ya un truc que
j'adore avec vous c'est que vous vous
prenez des nouvelles tout le temps sur
le plan humain c'est à dire vous dit
comment ça va etc
mais vous justifiez pas le choix
professionnel de pourquoi vous n'êtes là
et je vous ai toujours dit c'est comme
si dan l'entraîneur du real madrid il va
pas dire à ses joueurs pour quoi tu
joues pour quoi tu joues pas sinon il va
lire à 50 joueurs tu joues tu joue pas
il deviendrait fou donc je trouve très
bien parce que on est là on n'est pas là
c'est à nous de penser à comment faire
pour regagner sa place mais en plus rien
à venir etc c'est humainement
humainement
vous êtes là en permanence j'espère vous
qu'il s'agit de venir va être ta pas je
suis très heureuse pour eux je considère
toujours que c'est fini demain ça que je
sais qu'on a de la chance d'être là on a
la chance de dpi pour donner notre avis
sur un plateau moi je considère souvent
pas légitime
et j'ai l'impression d'être un imposteur
dont je me dise que je prends ce qui est
à prendre et moi j'ai toujours fait en
sorte d'avoir trois boulots de quatre
boules en même temps par peur d'avoir
rien en fait ma surtout pour faire les
soldes c'est vrai ça c'est important
eric naulleau il expliqué à l'antenne
quand il a arrêté la télévision en fait
on sécrète des hormones et oui
effectivement quand après on vient plus
parce que vous nous appelez plus parce
que voilà me changer de castine et sur
ça on a une descente en fait on a une
descente physiques et physiologiques
parce qu'il est prouvé que le direct
comme ça tous les jours à la même heure
on sécrète de le de l'endorphine
pourquoi s'arrêter alors moi ça valait
bien sûr vous avez un moment vous êtes
vous avez vous êtes on bat vous avez
vous êtes moins bien en bad nom met en
route pour l'égérie moyens voilà qui
monte qui monte je vous dis la vérité
jean-michel mairie mme mokraoui toujours
que c'est vrai voilà les mots me
manquent pas d'ailleurs je vois là il va
revenir vite j'ai appelé la syrie qu ils
sont excellents les deux voilà donc
voilà je le dis et c'est pas des
sanctions voilà on essaie de faire
tourner et vous delphine vous êtes
content d'être avec nous mais je suis
très contente et je suis contente de moi
aussi vous avez fait un départ et un
retour
ouais mais en fait il ya un an et demi
dedans quand j'étais là c'était
différent
voilà c'est indifférent et où des
référés cette année je sais ouais j'ai
senti qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
arrêter et et après j'ai aussi vraiment
une réflexion c'est émotionnellement
c'est vraiment pas facile parce qu'on se
demande effectivement pourquoi ça n'a
pas ça n'a pas aussi bien fonctionné et
je suis content je suis revenu en invité
ça a bien marché mais comme guillaume
aussi je me dis ça peut s'arrêter demain
il vaut mieux le prendre comme ça en
fait exactement on va les chéris merci
en tout cas on voulait parler de culture
carrière que je vois c'est que j'ai
essayé je vais voir s'ils vont revenir
en tout cas dans ouvert à tous au moins
déjà le vendredi
voilà on va essayer de s'occuper de sa
ligue